mein name ist bach meister europas mit
über meine dienstags in der hessenliga
2014 stabskompanie im verzug und über
dort meine dienst aus als kommandant zur
tat
wir stellen für das panzer parteien und
14 bei der handwerk nicht sind die
verbindung innerhalb des bataillons
sicher aufhört zur brigade und abwärts
zu den komponenten gleichzeitig für
ausbildung für militär und gwd tour dass
sie selbstständig eine funk stände
errichten und betreiben können
[Musik]
der großteil der mini zwar nicht das
verwendete insoweit 5 und 14
aber durch die hohe motivation und der
miliz und das intensive trainieren und
es geschafft dass innerhalb von
kürzester zeit das ausbildungsziel
erreicht haben